校長的にはトランプさんについてはどう
思っているとかあるんです
かあら言いたいこと言っとるじゃんだから
感じたままを言っとるんやねから多少時代
に合わんこともあるわさ当然ね昔とは違う
んやからもう世界がっと交流しちまっとる
んやからなアメリカだけ良ければええんだ
というあれは成り立たんわね特にこれだけ
気候変動がどうのこうの言っとる時に気候
変動を助長するようなこと言っとるわね
からそういうちょっと強引すぎるとこは
あるにしても全体としては本当にアメリカ
のためになると思うよ日本もああいうのが
出れええんやようやら言わんやろあんな
もんが出てみすぐヒットラーだって言い
出すみんなねリベラルに気がついたから
あれがよく言うのはトランプがアメリカを
2分化するって言っとるじゃん分断させる
保守しかんところにリベラルが割り込んで
きて分断したんやろそんなことをね逆転し
て平気で言う嘘つきの集まるよね1番
いかんのは自分のできないことを言うで
自分ができなくてことを人に押し付ける
だったらお前やってみろと言われたらほ
無理よねからLGBTなんてそう思わんか
あいつら本当にLGBTを平等に見れる
あれを平等に見たら人間としておかしい
やろなあそれが平等だなければならない早
いかんわな好調的には今回のトランプさん
の勝利っていうのは対立候補のリベラルが
あんまり指示されなかったから起きたって
いうリベラルの自滅やないかアメリカに
おる人はそう言っとったわねからリベラル
は何にも成果あげそれなのにを攻撃する何
を持って攻撃とるんや精神論自分たちの
精神論が正しいのにっていうのがあいつら
の唯一のより所やないかだけど正しくない
に決まっとるじゃん日本の教育見たらそう
やろらんでアメリカをもっと早くにそれに
気がついたでリベラルの教育をすると国が
潰れると思ってレガの時やねでリベラル
教育をもうやめ国を上げてやめて日本も
それぐらいやらんとねこれだけ結果が出て
ま東校拒否はもう戦後最大やろとんでも
ない数になっちまってこれ教育がダメと
いうことやねそういう人間を作らんために
教育しとるんやないかから特にいかんのは
ねああいう風になると一生ダメなんだ結局
彼らはね自分は何のために生まれてきたん
だということになっちまうでうつうつとし
て一生過ごす死刑よりもっと悪いわ
なだから日本の国際争力が今何かしとる
38位かなもう39位になっとるかもしれ
ん太より下やで太陽馬鹿にしとったやない
かそっちの方が上になっちまっとるんや
どうしてや教育が悪かったからに決まっ
とるじゃんね教育のどこが悪かったの教育
というのは地域徳育体育のだどれが悪かっ
たのね1番悪かったのは
得意人間がダメになってんなからチーク
なんてやってないじゃない覚えること
ばっかりやらせるんやからあれチークや
ないもんね体育全くやってないわな今学校
でやってるのはスポーツあれは体育じゃ
ないそうやねでマスゴミはしごくのは
けしからんて言うんじゃん動かなかったら
体育は成り立たん効果が出ないねそれ日本
が真似するイギリスなんか見てこらん
パブリックスクール午後みんな体育やで
いわゆる地区これは午前中だけよそれ
ぐらい熱心に体育やるこれは体育が意味を
持っとるからよねでえまそれにしても1番
いかんのは得意だ人間性を高める人間性を
高めるということはは強くするということ
ところがあのリベラルどもは強いのは悪い
ことじゃないみんな平均やないといかんの
やからそっから出てはいかんのよだから
みんなダメになっちゃって人間性が低く
なるの当たり前じゃん人間性が高いと強い
という強いと
優しい
ねコロナで学校がずっと急行になっちまっ
て授業が足らんようになった時に後で補充
する時に体育は補充戦やったよねあれが
もう無償の体育に対する態度だ体育から
補助していかねね誰らいかんのはダメに
なったら助けてやればええんだという生
意気よね誰が助けてもらうか男ならそう
思うやろ自分でやるわいというだから
ちゃんとやれるようにしろよというこれが
本当のとこよねだけど品たらそれでも
行ける場所を作ってやる最初はあれやった
ね保健室投稿やってだ保健室が飛行の
たまり場になっちまったのねでそれをやめ
て今度は登校拒否の子供が行く学校無住に
よねこれ登校拒否の子供が行く学校を作っ
てでそこへ集めればええんだとできるよう
にしてやればええやないかというばっかな
考えよねいらんことするなよて俺は努力し
て普通の学校へ行くよというのが普通
当たり前のことないだけどもうその力が
なくなっちまっとる小さい頃から甘やかさ
れたんやから都合悪くなるとすぐ誰かが
助けてくれたんやからあれはね不快感が
人間を行動させるんやその不快感を取り
やがるんやだったら行動しないじゃないな
それが正しい教育リベラルだ体育を警視
する生徒目線で体育を警視するのは受験
科目に体育がないからっていのは結構
大きいかなと思うんですけどそれはどうお
考えですかなそうやろねだけど受験で全て
が決まるという制度をなんとかせことには
これは続くわねだけど体育の重要さが
分かってないから体育を警視するという
これも言えるわねだから体育のはちゃんと
充実してさらに受験もじ自分でやれよと
受験は自分でやるもんであってねやって
もらうもんやないよがそれを乗り越えて
受験したんなら偏差主催じゃないわね
ちゃんとした済になるやろだけど勉強
ばっかりさせられて成績が良くなってで
大学行ったこれは偏差主催よね実際の行動
が伴ってないからさえね行動が伴わないと
全てダメというこれが分からんとねだから
現場じゃないといかんからああいうリベラ
ルっていうのは現場をを嫌うはね自分たち
はやってないからね体育をちゃんと重視
するような制度にするにはどうすればいい
ですかねも文部省がやれええじゃん体育の
時間を増やして体育をしっかりやれ
と横浜の小学校でねうちのトレーニングを
取り入れたいという要望があっただいぶ前
だでその校長先生からの依頼でないっぺん
行って合何回やったかな3回か4回やった
んよで1回目のトレーニングの時にその
学校の1番の問題時というのが俺について
きちまってねであの校長室に行ったら一緒
に校長室に着いてくるんやそうすと校長
先生がびっくりしてんのあの子が校長室に
来るなんてて言い出してな大ぶよなった
ねって言ったのたて1回やででじゃああと
もうちょっとやろうよと言って3回ぐらい
やったかねそしたらね
プール使ってやるんやけどな生徒が大組で
うーと騒ぎ出すんやと近所の人が集まって
きてな中には車で来た人もおるから
ちょっと遠くから来たんやで遠くまで
聞こえとったんやほれでどうしたの言う
たらこんな子供の声本当に久しぶりに聞い
た何年ぶりやろ言っとるんやからみんな
シーンとしとるんや学校がそんな中で教育
ができるわけないじゃんね人間教育は
そんなもんではできんのな思いっきりな
精神を発散する感情を発散するそれで
初めて人間教育ができるんやそれがシーン
としとったっていうんだから全然やって
なかったということなんやねそれは何を
やったんですかああうちのボード
トレーニングでしかもねその後があるんや
でじゃあほらこんな簡単なことなんだから
学校の事業体育の時間に取り入れたらどう
ですかた日教祖の反対があって無理や日
教祖なんで反対するの戸がやっとることだ
から悪いことに決まっとるってそういう
反対の仕方やったでそれを校長がやるのは
けしからんというで校長を突き上げてやめ
さしたんやね日教祖と校長の話結構よく出
てくるんですけどだいぶ中がよろしくない
感じなですか私とはいああ私も馬鹿にし
とるもん日教争お前なんか教師じゃないよ
大体教育をやる人は教育は生殖なんだで日
教祖のやつらあれ自分たちを労働者にした
んやだから青毛は唐市を歌ってもらえんの
やろ青いだって尊くないよ普通のあれや
もんでな自分たちを高めてくれない生殖者
だったら自分たちを高めてくれるやないか
だから先生のおかげで自分たちが進歩した
高まったという実感が全然持てんもんで
尊くないよねだから先生は馬鹿にされる
いうこと聞いてくれんひどい時には校内
暴力を起こさせるそうなっちまうんやから
先生が非常にこう科学的になってちゃんと
成果を上げ出したらまた青毛とになるねね
だから今先生の成りたが少なくなっちまっ
て困っとるやろダメの商売になった職業に
ね本当は先生というのは最高の職ないあれ
ほど素晴らしい職業はない自分でも満足
できるんやえっとね私の言うことは正しい
ことばっかりだだから今からまだ続くから
正しい人生死ぬ時に満足の行く人生それを
送りたければチャンネル登録してずっと
聞いてくれ